اتهم وزير الدفاع في جمهوريه قصبه اميد
نهائي
بالوقوف خلف التوترات الاخيره الشماليه
لن تتسامح مع ما وصفها بالاصابات
الاجراميه التي لا تحترمه حكم القانون
تاتي بتعليمات من السلطات في صربيا
ومجموعات اجراميه مسموح لها منذ وقت طويل
بلاعبي دور لا يقبلون فيه بحكم القانون
وهذا امر مهم جدا لحكوماتنا نحن ديمقراطيه
ونحترم حكم القانون والعداله وحقوق
الانسان وفي هذه الحاله لا يمكننا ترك
المجرمين يفعلون ما يشاءون ويلحقون الاداب
البلد والاقتصاد والناس والامن
هذا هو قال وزير الدفاع عن الكوسوفي من
القوات الامنيه التي يقودها مفتوحه في وجه
الصرب وجميع الاقليات
وموضح اننا مشكله بلاده مع السلطات
السلبيه وليست مع الاقليه الصربيه من
المواطنين
نحن في وزاره الدفاع وقوات الامن لدينا
سرب يخدمون وهي مفتوحه في وجه جميع
الاعراق بشكل متساوي وعادل وهذا امر نتبعه
في كل خطوه هم جزء من قوه الدفاع وهم جزء
مهم في بناء الدوله عندما نتحدث عن السرب
في الشمال فنحن نقصد النظام الصربي
والمجرمين الصرب من المهم جدا تعريف ذلك
شعب بل المجرمين والمسلمين والمرتبطين
بالنظام السلبي